[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es wieder ein Nachgemacht-Rezept.
Ich habe in meinem Team gefragt:
Wer hat eine Idee? Wer hat einen Wunsch? Wer hat ein Anliegen?
Der Tolga hat sich etwas ausgedacht.
TOLGA: Hello. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Zeig mal!
Eins will ich dazu sagen: Der Tolga hat gesagt, was er mitbringt.
Eins will ich euch sagen… Man sagt ja niemals nie,
aber ich würde niemals bei Starbucks etwas kaufen.
Also habe ich aber gesagt:
Komm Tolga! Aus wissenschaftlichen Zwecken brauchen wir den Kuchen.
Er soll ja originalgetreu werden.
Deswegen mache ich ihn nach und danach kaufe ich ihn nie wieder
und ihr macht alle das Rezept nach. Bingo!
Okay. Komm, lass uns ihn probieren.
TOLGA: Carrot Cake.
SALLY: Erste Frage: Sind es zwei Stücke? [Tolga bejaht]
Und die sind so lieblos eingepackt? [Tolga lacht und bejaht]
Echt jetzt?
Haben die einfach den einen mit Boden und den anderen mit Deckel?
TOLGA: Ja, einfach obendrauf.
SALLY: Ist jetzt nicht dein Ernst! Und was kostet das?
TOLGA: Zu viel.
SALLY: Wie viel? Sag es mir.
TOLGA: 1 Stück 3,99 €.
SALLY: Was? 1 Stück 4 €? Du hast jetzt 8 € gezahlt?
Hast du einen Kassenbeleg? Dann gebe ich dir die 8 €.
TOLGA: Ja, habe ich [Kassiergeräusch], aber egal!
SALLY: 8 € für 2?
TOLGA: Deswegen sollst du ihn nachmachen.
Dann kann ich ihn zu Hause machen. [Lacht]
SALLY: Oh mein Gott! Hast du ein Bild von der ganzen Torte gemacht?
Ich würde gern wissen, wie viele Stücke die in ihrer Torte haben.
Sind es 12 oder 24?
TOLGA: 24, weil sie die alle so ganz klein schneiden.
SALLY: Aaah, 24 mal 4 – oh mein Gott!
Überleg dir mal, was die für einen Gewinn an der Torte haben.
TOLGA: So macht man Geld.
SALLY: Aber hallo! Danke!
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn. Also für 8 € …
Wir können ja später einmal die Zutaten von mir grob überschlagen
und gucken, was sie kosten, aber da kostet 1 Stück nicht 4 €.
Okay. Komm, wir probieren ihn, damit ich weiß, was drinsteckt.
Ich habe übrigens grade noch versucht, zu schauen, was drin ist,
also online Zutaten und Allergene, aber ich habe nichts gefunden,
nur Allergene, aber nirgends, was drin ist.
Deswegen müssen wir es herausschmecken.
TOLGA: Die Creme ist schon hart, ne?
SALLY: Die Creme ist schon Hardcore, aber auch süß.
Also ich würde es ein bisschen weniger süß zubereiten.
Aber ich sehe schon: Walnüsse…
TOLGA: Rosinen. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Wobei…
TOLGA: Die sind so schwarz. [Sally stimmt zu]
Das frage ich mich auch jedes Mal. Ich habe noch nie schwarze gesehen.
SALLY: Hä? Was ist das? Das ist eine Nuss. [Tolga stimmt zu]
Schwarze Walnuss. Vielleicht sind sie fermentiert oder so.
Aber er ist schön saftig. Man sieht die Karottenstücke,
Cream Cheese Frosting wahrscheinlich, weil in Amerika ganz oft
Cream Cheese, also Frischkäse Frosting verwendet.
Hier habe ich eine Rosine.
TOLGA: Denkst du, das ist Zimt oder Tonka?
SALLY: Ich glaube, Zimt.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen Kardamom oder so.
Warum habe ich 2 Gabeln? [Tolga lacht]
Und hier oben ein Gitter aus weißer Schokolade.
Okay, ich versuche jetzt den Kuchen nachzumachen.
Das lassen wir noch übrig, dass wir später…
Vielleicht machen wir noch eine Blindverkostung.
TOLGA: Ich schneide das dann einfach hier ab. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Ich sehe hier außen noch dekoriert mit braunem Zucker?
TOLGA: Kuchenkrümel.
SALLY: Ja. Weißt du aber, was ich nicht mag
und das schmecke ich jetzt hier heraus?
Ich schmecke heraus, dass der Kuchen im Kühlschrank
nicht abgedeckt war, bei denen in der Theke.
TOLGA: Ist er auch nicht.
SALLY: Ich mag das nicht.
Ich mag es nicht, wenn ein Kuchen nicht abgedeckt ist.
Dann schmeckt er nach Kühlschrank und das schmecke ich hier heraus.
TOLGA: Der ist nicht abgedeckt.
SALLY: Man schmeckt es dann an der Creme.
Okay. Ich zeige euch meine Zutaten.
Es ist definitiv einfacher, sich einfach den Kuchen zu kaufen.
Auf jeden Fall; muss ich zugeben, denn es sind schon viele Zutaten,
aber ich wette… Komm, wir machen jetzt „Wetten, dass..?“
Wetten, dass ich den Carrot Cake von Starbucks leckerer hinbekomme
als bei Starbucks?
SALLY UND JOSH: Top, die Wette gilt!
SALLY: Dedüüüüm.
Dafür verwende ich 100 g Rosinen, 50 g Apfelsaft,
400 g Karotten – das sind Biokarotten, deswegen schäle ich sie nicht,
sondern habe sie nur gewaschen und ein bisschen geputzt -,
150 g Walnüsse, 250 g weiche Butter,
jeweils 125 g Zucker und braunen Zucker, Vanilleextrakt, 4 Eier,
400 g Mehl – hier haben wir ein bisschen was verschüttet… egal! -,
Salz, Kakao, Backpulver, Natron, Zimt,
Kardamom und Ingwer, der hier so herumliegt, und Buttermilch.
Also die Rosinen jetzt einfach in Apfelsaft tränken,
denn wenn man sie ganz trocken in den Teig gibt,
dann kann es passieren, wenn sie gerade auf der Teigoberfläche sind,
dass sie schnell verbrennen.
D.h., hier jetzt schön mit Apfelsaft überdecken.
Ich dachte eigentlich, 50 g reichen,
aber ich habe jetzt doch mehr benutzt.
Ich drücke es dann später einfach aus.
Ich lasse sie jetzt hier kurz stehen.
Dann habe ich jetzt hier die Walnüsse.
Die könnt ihr entweder so direkt verwenden
oder ihr röstet sie noch in der Pfanne ohne Fett
– das mache ich jetzt.
So intensiviert sich das Aroma der Walnüsse.
Einfach bei mittelhoher Hitze.
Immer mal schauen, dass sie nicht verbrennen.
Das war jetzt die zweite Vorbereitung.
Die dritte Vorbereitung: Karotten raspeln.
Die Karotten rasple ich einfach hier oben im Multi-Zerkleinerer;
schön fein. Also ich habe eine grobe und eine feine Reibe.
Ich nehme jetzt die feine, weil sie ansonsten im Kuchen zu grob wird.
[Musik]
Dann habe ich jetzt hier die weiche Butter.
Sie kommt in die Rührschüssel.
In amerikanischen Rezepten ist auch ganz oft,
dass man braunen Zucker verwendet.
Dieser schmeckt auch ein bisschen malziger,
wobei oft brauner Zucker einfach nur gefärbter Zucker ist,
aber ihr könnt z.B. auch Zucker und dann noch Zuckerrübensirup nehmen
oder Kokosblütenzucker; der schmeckt auch schön malzig.
Ich mische das jetzt hier einfach mit normalem Zucker.
Ich würde mal schätzen, dass im Original Carrot Cake
wahrscheinlich mindestens 1/3 mehr Zucker drinsteckt,
aber ich finde, das reicht auf jeden Fall,
denn Karotten sind auch süß. Dann kommt noch die Creme dazu.
Es wird schon relativ süß, aber nicht bei uns.
Jetzt 5-10 Min. verrühren, bis es eine schöne weißcremige Masse ist.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Butterzuckermasse weißcremig
und ich kann die Eier einfach dazugeben.
Vergesst übrigens die Walnüsse nicht.
Meine sehen jetzt so aus wie die von Starbucks.
Ich glaube, so haben sie das gemacht, Josh.
Die haben sie einfach zu lange geröstet.
JOSH: Dann haben sie gedacht: Ach okay, wir lassen es jetzt so.
SALLY: Mein Gehör war bei der Maschine
und mein Geruchssinn war dann nicht da,
weil mein Gehirn das Küchenmaschinengeräusch verarbeitet hat
und meine Nase das nicht gerochen hat.
So. So nämlich. [Lacht]
Jetzt gebe ich die Eier einzeln dazu
und rühre sie immer etwa 30 Sek. ein.
[Küchenmaschine]
Uiiii.
[TikTok-Sound] Abada Uiiii. [Lacht]
[Musik]
Ich zerdrücke sie gerade nur ein bisschen,
weil sie schon recht grob waren.
Dann geht es jetzt eigentlich relativ schnell,
denn es kommen alle anderen Zutaten hier in die Schüssel.
Karotten, dann siebe ich die trockenen Zutaten dazu.
[Musik]
Dann die Buttermilch. Ich nehme jetzt hier Buttermilch,
weil ich ein bisschen Säure brauche,
weil ich auch Natron benutzt habe.
Ja, es ist eine große Menge.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen gekleckst.
Ich glaube sogar fast, ich brauche den ganzen Apfelsaft.
Ich glaube, ich nehme ihn doch komplett.
Also wirklich die 100 g Apfelsaft mit den Rosinen mit rein.
Jetzt nur noch kurz verrühren, bis sich alles verbunden hat.
Die Walnüsse gebe ich auch gleich dazu - und vorsichtig rühren.
[Musik]
Der Teig ist jetzt fertig. Optisch, finde ich, sieht er ganz gut aus.
Sieht auch so aus wie der Kuchen, finde ich.
Jetzt muss ich ihn noch probieren,
denn falls jetzt doch noch etwas an Gewürzen oder Geschmack fehlt,
kann ich es jetzt noch dazugeben, später nicht mehr.
[Musik]
Aber durch das Backen intensiviert sich das Aroma.
Ich lasse es mal. Ich lasse es mal so.
Ihr seht jetzt hier 4 Tortenringe.
Ihr müsst nicht in 4 Tortenringen backen,
aber das Starbucks-Original ist vierschichtig,
vier einzelne Tortenböden.
Ich habe auch gesehen, sie sind auch einzeln gebacken,
denn die Nüsse sind relativ grob.
Dann ist es später ein bisschen problematisch,
da den Boden schön durchzuschneiden.
Ihr könnt aber, wenn ihr sagt, ihr habt keine vier Tortenringe
und ihr wollt auch nicht in zwei Backöfen gleichzeitig backen,
auch in einem Tortenring backen, dann aber nicht 20 cm,
sondern ein bisschen größerer Durchmesser, bisschen länger backen
und niedrigere Temperatur.
Ich mache es jetzt einfach so, weil es für mich einfacher ist
und ich dann vier gleichmäßige Böden haben werde.
Die Backzeit verkürzt sich auch. Ich bin insgesamt schneller fertig,
aber wie gesagt, ihr könnt auch in einem Backofen backen
und auch gern bei Heißluft zwei Bleche hinein. Das funktioniert auch.
Jetzt schön gleichmäßig aufteilen.
[Musik]
Dann schön verstreichen. Den Ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt.
Dann können die Böden direkt gebacken werden.
Ich kann in der Zwischenzeit schon einmal das Frosting zubereiten,
also die Creme.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Für die Creme verwende ich 250 g weiche Butter, 125 g Puderzucker,
Vanilleextrakt und 250 g Frischkäse.
Die Böden sind gebacken und abgekühlt und es geht an die Creme.
Ich muss sagen, ein Cream Cheese Frosting, ein originales,
ist sehr fettig und sehr süß.
Ich werde das Ganze ein bisschen weniger fettig und süß zubereiten.
[Lacht]
Das eine Ding ist raus… egal!
Deswegen eigentlich auch nur 125 g Puderzucker,
denn in originalen amerikanischen Rezepten ist es mindestens doppelt,
wenn nicht sogar dreimal so viel.
Auf diese Menge hätten sie… warte mal… locker 500 g Puderzucker.
Das ist schon viel, finde ich. Also ich… Ah, das muss nicht sein.
Jetzt Vanilleextrakt dazu und schön weißcremig verrühren.
Bei Frischkäse ist meine Erfahrung…
Ich benutze seit Jahren immer Philadelphia,
gerade in Torten und Tortencremes.
Da weiß ich einfach:
Die Doppelrahmstufe hat keinen ekeligen Eigengeschmack.
Sie schmeckt sehr gut, passt sich immer gut an
und die Konsistenz wird einfach auch fest.
Denn ich habe auch schon andere Marken und Sorten getestet.
Nicht alle natürlich; es gibt mit Sicherheit auch welche,
die gut funktionieren.
Ihr könnt es auch gern in die Kommentare schreiben,
aber ich hatte auch schon Eigenmarken…
da wird die Creme einfach nicht fest und die Torte ist zerlaufen.
Deswegen bin ich da bekennender Philadelphia-Fan bei Torten.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Musik]
Wenn die Masse so aussieht,
dann jetzt den Frischkäse ganz langsam dazugeben
[Küchenmaschine]
und schön cremig weiterrühren.
[Musik]
Also, die Tortencreme ist fertig. Die Böden sind auch gebacken.
Ich habe sie schon herausgelöst.
Ich habe jetzt hier auch noch das Backpapier
bzw. die Folie einmal hiergelassen,
denn ich brauche die Tortenkrümel.
Die hebe ich für den Rand auf. Ich kratze sie auch generell immer ab.
Dann ist das Putzen der Folie nämlich einfacher.
Dann nehme ich den ersten Boden.
Es kann sein, dass einer der Böden vielleicht nicht ganz eben ist.
Dann könnt ihr einfach eine Tortensäge nehmen, das Ganze eben machen
und habt dann noch ein bisschen mehr Krümel.
Der sieht super aus,
aber ich glaube, der sieht ein bisschen schief aus. Wenn nicht,
kann ich die Tortenkrümel außen auch ein bisschen mit Keks krümeln.
Das kriege ich schon hin.
Diese sind leider alle zu perfekt.
Deswegen haben wir keine Krümel.
Hast du dir das auch gerade gedacht? [Lacht]
Ich war so: Komm, sei schief! Nein, die sind zu perfekt.
Egal, dann schneide ich da nichts herunter.
Ich nehme später einfach Kekse.
Jetzt kommt hier eine Schicht Buttercreme hinein.
Manchmal frage ich mich, warum ich immer Miniwerkzeug nehme.
Aber dann denke ich mir: Sie sind halt so süß!
So schichtet ihr jetzt die ganze Torte.
Natürlich ein bisschen Creme für Rand und Oberfläche übriglassen,
also nicht alles aufbrauchen.
[Musik]
Ich finde, der wäre auch als Naked-Cake hübsch,
aber wir machen ihn originalgetreu.
Deswegen hier die Creme noch ein bisschen glattziehen.
Ich stelle die Torte kurz in den Kühlschrank,
damit sie fest wird
und ich sie dann gleich komplett einstreichen kann,
aber riecht jetzt schon einmal sehr gut und sehr originalgetreu.
Etwa 15-20/30 Min., dann können wir gleich weitermachen.
[Uhr]
Jetzt ist die Torte schön angekühlt.
Ich habe auf dem Foto gesehen
- der Tolga hat mir nämlich noch ein Foto von der Theke gemacht -,
wie die Torte dort aussieht.
Sie ist so ein bisschen Semi-Naked,
d.h., der Rand ist zwar glattgestrichen,
aber man noch ein bisschen durchschauen.
Die Oberfläche ist relativ… Warum lachst du?
JOSH: Bikini-Torte.
SALLY: [Lacht] Genau, das ist so eine Bikini-Torte.
Man sieht eigentlich, was drunter ist,
aber man sieht es nicht komplett. [Lacht]
Eine Bikini-Torte, ja!
Die Oberfläche ist mit einem Gitter schön glatt.
Also wenn jemand dabeisteht,
der noch nie etwas von einer Naked-Torte gehört hat,
ist das immer so: Hä, was will sie von mir?
Dann habe ich auch immer das Bedürfnis, alles zu erklären.
Ich finde, eine Bikini-Torte könnte der neue Begriff sein.
Guck mal, ich glätte immer erst die Oberfläche mit der Palette.
Ihr könnt auch eine längere nehmen,
aber gut, ist auch eine kleine Torte.
Mit einer längeren Palette ist es praktisch in weniger Umdrehungen.
Das ist der Vorteil, aber gut!
Dann nehme ich für den Rand eine Teigkarte.
Die hat nämlich sozusagen den rechten Winkel. Hier auch.
Dann kann ich sie ansetzen und dann braucht es wirklich auch nicht
viel Handwerkskunst. Ich sage nicht gar keine, sondern nicht viel.
Man setzt hier an und geht dann hier noch drumherum
und kann dann hier unten die Lücken füllen und noch einmal drumherum
und dann ist sie eigentlich schon fast glatt.
[Musik]
Dann hier oben den Rand hineinwischen.
Hier einfach immer wieder die Palette sauberstreichen,
von einem Zug von außen nach innen.
[Musik]
Die kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Dann kann ich schon einmal Wasser aufsetzen,
denn ich werde jetzt gleich Kuvertüre für die Oberfläche schmelzen.
Dann kommen die Krümel dran – fertig! Easy peasy!
Habe ich gerade „easy peasy“ gesagt?
„Easy cheesy“ sagen Samira und Ela immer.
Jetzt wird die Torte fertig dekoriert.
Ich nehme jetzt Kuvertüre wegen diesem Kuvertüregitter.
Da habe ich jetzt hier 60 g schon so portioniert,
dass hier praktisch 40 g habe, also 2/3 weiße Kuvertüre.
Diese kann ich jetzt hier über das Wasserbad geben.
Da mache ich es immer so:
Wasser kochen lassen und dann den Herd ausschalten.
Hier habe ich noch 1/3, also 20 g
und 1 TL Kokosöl.
Für die Deko nehme ich noch diese weißen Schokoladen-Crisps.
Das ist praktisch im Inneren ein Keks umhüllt mit weißer Kuvertüre.
Jetzt warte ich kurz, bis das hier geschmolzen ist.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich jetzt hier so ein Mini-Spritzbeutel.
Ihr könnt aber auch eine Gefriertüte
oder auch die Dosierflasche nehmen.
Wenn es hier geschmolzen ist, vom Herd herunternehmen und, wie gesagt,
das restliche Drittel Kuvertüre und das Kokosfett dazugeben.
Kokosöl gebe ich dazu,
damit die Kuvertüre später nicht so sehr beim Anschneiden bricht
und ich dann sozusagen eine geschmeidigere Konsistenz habe.
Ich habe das Ganze jetzt hier schön temperiert.
Die Schokolade ist jetzt nicht zu heiß
und bekommt dann auch keinen grauen Schleier
und wird dann trotzdem schön fest.
Deswegen macht man immer diese Impfmethode - diese 1/3, 2/3-Prozedur.
[Musik]
Passt. Und wenn es klümpchenfrei ist, schön umfüllen.
Dann schneide ich da oben eine kleine Spitze weg
und mache jetzt einfach ein Gitter darauf.
[Musik]
Dann die Crispearls darauf.
Ich will nämlich,
dass meine Torte schöner wird als die Starbucks-Torte. [Lacht]
Vor allem hat man dann einen Crunch dabei.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier noch die Bröselchen,
und weil ich nicht so viele Kuchenkrümel habe,
nehme ich noch Lotuskekse,
zerbrösle sie und drücke sie dann an den Rand. Das passt auch.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich einfach die Schokolade vom Rand noch hier drauf.
Dann könnt ihr jetzt hier die Kekskrümel drandrücken.
Ich mache das jetzt einfach mit einer Teigkarte. Das geht ganz gut.
[Musik]
Ich stelle den Kuchen kurz in den Kühlschrank,
dass er noch einmal schön fest wird,
setze ihn auf eine Tortenplatte um und dann wird verkostet.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie Tolga diese Torte schmeckt.
[Musik]
Okay. Meine Starbucks-Torte.
Also ich finde, so rein optisch könnte der Anschnitt
genauso aus dieser Torte kommen, oder?
Okay, Tolga. Gefällt sie dir optisch?
TOLGA: Ich finde, sie sieht sogar viel besser aus.
SALLY: Das sind die White Crisps. [Lacht]
Ich glaube, dass sie das Gitter auf jeden Fall maschinell…
aber es wird gespritzt, ausgestochen und draufgelegt.
Die kann man ja ganz gut mit Schokolade zubereiten.
TOLGA: Sieht man ja.
SALLY: Die sieht Handmade aus, finde ich.
Aber so der Anschnitt könnte echt exakt dieselbe Torte sein.
TOLGA: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
SALLY: Sie ist ein bisschen rötlicher, finde ich.
Die Karotten sind auch rot. [Tolga stimmt zu]
TOLGA: Du hast sogar auch hier schwarze Walnüsse. [Lacht]
SALLY: Das war so gewollt. Weißt du, wie das geht?
Man stelle die Walnüsse auf den Herd und vergesse sie.
[Beide lachen]
So haben die das auch gemacht. Deswegen sind sie so.
Okay. Komm, wir probieren!
Das ist original.
[Beide lachen]
TOLGA: Wobei ich sie noch besser finde.
SALLY: Weil nicht so süß? [Tolga bejaht]
Dann hat man mehr Geschmack. Ich bin so…
SALLY: Und dieser ist mir auch schon süß genug.
TOLGA: Dieser ist viel besser!
SALLY: Wenn ich jetzt überlege,
ich hatte im Teig je 125 g weißen und braunen Zucker,
also 250 g plus 125 g in der Creme = 375 g.
In amerikanischen Rezepten ist es oft so,
da ist schon im Teig mehr drin als bei mir in der gesamten Torte.
Die Creme haben die locker 500 g Puderzucker noch einmal zusätzlich.
Also das ist einfach nur eine Zuckerbombe.
TOLGA: Ich probiere einmal kurz im Vergleich.
SALLY: Ah, das ist der Wahnsinn. Die Torte ist echt der Wahnsinn.
SALLY: Warte, wir lassen jetzt noch Jutta probieren. Komm!
Wir brauchen jetzt noch eine andere Meinung.
Josh, willst du auch einmal probieren?
Hast du das Original probiert?
JOSH: Nein.
JUTTA: Ich muss dann erst das… [Beide stimmen zu]
Hallo!
SALLY: Hier, die ist sauber.
Josh!
Weil ich finde, wenn wir zwei das jetzt sagen…
Wir backen auch viel; Tolga backt auch viel.
Wir haben ja vorher probiert.
Ich glaube, in der Blindverkostung – das wäre wichtig zu wissen…
Ich finde, das bitzelt auf der Zunge.
TOLGA: Da ist irgendetwas.
SALLY: Ich glaube, da ist mehr Ingwer oder so etwas drin.
TOLGA: Aber es ist krass, wenn man diesen probiert…
JUTTA: Das ist sehr süß. Absolut. [Sally stimmt zu]
Das ist das, was ich meine.
SALLY: Und? Das war… warte. Wovon habe ich dir jetzt gegeben?
TOLGA: Von deinem, oder? Ich weiß es nicht.
SALLY: Ah, wir müssen es noch einmal…
Also Josh, komm, ich mache dir jetzt gleich zwei Gabeln.
[Jutta lacht]
Gabel 1 = Starbucks.
Gabel 2 = Sally.
Leute, es ist das Originalrezept in gut.
TOLGA: Schmeckt man, oder?
JOSH: Deiner ist auch viel, viel luftiger.
[Alle stimmen zu]
JUTTA: Aber das sieht man auch schon. Der ist viel kompakter.
TOLGA: Es schmeckt wirklich original, einfach nur frischer.
SALLY: Besser.
Danke für die Idee, liebster Tolga.
TOLGA: Danke für das Rezept.
SALLY: Liebes Sally-Team, falls ihr Wünsche, Anregungen
und Verbesserungsvorschläge habt, gern in der Küche melden.
Liebe Sally-Community, falls ihr Wünsche, Anregungen
und Verbesserungsvorschläge hat, gern in die Kommentare.
TOLGA: Nie wieder zu Starbucks.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Tschüss!
JUTTA: Ciao!
TOLGA: Das ist um Welten besser!
SALLY: Das ist richtig gut.
Und… man ist ja so gespaltener Meinung:
Es gibt Menschen, die mögen Rosinen, und Menschen, die mögen sie nicht.
Aber hier im Kuchen, finde ich, müssen sie sein.
Man schmeckt sie nicht als Rosinen heraus,
weil alles drumherum mehr Geschmack hat,
aber sie geben dem Kuchen und dem Teig so eine Konsistenz.
Auch wenn ihr Rosinenhasser seid
– in diesem Kuchen schmeckt ihr es nicht heraus
und sie schmecken einfach Bombe!
Und noch einmal zum Preis: Aus der Torte kann man 12 Stücke schneiden,
12 mal 4, oder? 40… 48?
TOLGA: Ich muss auch kurz überlegen.
Ich glaube, der kostet sogar 4,99 €.
SALLY: [Tiefes Einatmen] 4,99 €?!
TOLGA: Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
SALLY: Okay, ich sage jetzt einmal im Schnitt 50 €.
Die Zutaten haben keine 50 € gekostet.
Ich blende euch hier ein, wie viel sie gekostet haben.
Tolga rechnet es jetzt aus. [Lacht]
Nein, aber komm, ganz ehrlich. Das sind nicht so viele Zutaten.
Von daher lohnt sich selbst backen!
Man kann auch die einzelnen Stücke einfrieren
und immer, wenn man Lust auf eine Torte hat
- denn sind wir mal ganz ehrlich:
Die backen das dort auch nicht vor Ort frisch.
Das wird auch immer geliefert und eingefroren,
dann aufgetaut, wie so eine fertige Torte.
Ihr könnt euch die Stücke einzeln einfrieren.
Immer, wenn ihr Lust auf ein Stück Starbucks Carrot Cake habt,
einfach auftauen.
Tschüss!
Und… wirklich Tschüss! [Lacht]
[Musik]